The joe rogan experience.
So I'm,
I'm playing with the idea of dark spiritual forces at work behind human history,
manipulating Moctezuma,
manipulating Cortez and plunging mankind into the sea of,
of cruelty and misery.
Um,
and you know,
what redeems the story for me and does it at all times,
is that the human spirit's still shines through.
Even in the darkest times.
There is courage,
there is decency,
there is love people.
People struggle to show the best in themselves and,
and,
and to deliver the best in themselves.
So I've tried to show both sides of this.
This book is about the battle of good against evil.
And it's not that the Spanish are good and the Aztecs are evil because the
Spanish were wicked,
wicked,
wicked as well.
Um,
and they did terrible things.
They fed people to dogs.
Um,
they,
they burned people at the state.
What is actually burning somebody at the stake,
if not a form of human sacrifice.
That's what the Spanish were due to.
Their God.
They were sacrificing people to,
their gods are no different from the Aztec.
So in that respect,
the level of sacrifice was so insane that I,
I tried to explain it to a friend of mine and he literally told me I was
bullshitting when I told them that 80,000 people were sacrificed.
Thousand were sacrificed period of like,
like four days,
four days,
uh,
with teams of killers,
50 teams of killers working at the top of the great pyramid to process people
within a minute or two.
Um,
processed them.
The think of it,
that's how it's done.
It was done on an industrial scale.
Cues of victims stretching a mile in every direction,
uh,
marching up the pyramid and having there and having their hearts cut out.
And all of this in honor of a,
of a demonic,
uh,
demonic entity,
which the Aztecs passionately believed in.
They believed that he needed to be fed human hearts and blood.
And when they call,
they called him Witsell a poshly,
which means hummingbird at the left hand of the son.
He's the war God after whom,
this after whom this novel is a,
is,
is named.
Uh,
and he,
I,
the way,
the way I look at it,
the same demonic entities manipulating both Moctezuma and Cortez,
he appears to Cortez in dreams and takes on the disguise of Saint Peter.
He appears to Moctezuma as the,
as the war God,
but it's the same demon that's playing with men.
And that's one reason why I wrote this is a novel because you can't get into
this stuff in a nonfiction book,
but it's very real.
It's a very real part of human history and the whole shape of the world we live
in today.
The,
the terrible genocide that happened in North America,
the destruction of the North American Indians,
the,
the conquest of Peru,
the whole relationship of the European powers to,
to Africa,
for example.
All of this was based on what happened in those years between 15,
19 and 15,
21 when the Spanish conquest of Mexico and folded.
Um,
and,
uh,
I think we would lead on to a dark track.
Imagine how it could have been if those two cultures,
if the Spanish and the Aztecs had met one another in a spirit of mutual
learning,
how much there was to exchange,
how much each side of the Atlantic could have learned from the other.
Instead of three,
it becomes this kind of conflagration of,
uh,
of,
of blood.
But it's difficult to place ourselves in the mindset of the people of that time.
It is difficult for us to do that today.
Um,
and I have to say,
when you look at the Spaniards,
I mean 490 men turn up on the coast of Mexico in 11 ships and they are going to
take on this empire that can put 200,000 men into the field that will,
if they catch you,
will match you up the pyramid and cut your heart out.
And many Spaniards were sacrificed,
uh,
in sight of their,
of their colleagues.
Um,
it was an extraordinary time.
It was an extraordinary event and men of those times were different from,
from men of today,
I believe.
What is the main stream explanation for human sacrifice?
Like what?
What do they believe started off?
Well,
that it's that it's a feeding of psychic energy to supernatural beings.
That's what human sacrifices about that,
that,
that you take the psychic energy of the individual,
you're going to kill you,
kill them,
take their psychic energy and feed it to these vampire like creatures that are
lying in the beyond that,
that thrive on human misery and pain.
And you know,
who are we to say that such things do not exist?
We don't understand the nature of reality.
And if you look at human culture day,
I mean look at wars.
Look at wars that are happening in the world today.
Look at the tens of thousands of people that are being slaughtered in a warfare
today.
That's also a kind of human sacrifice.
I think we have to consider the possibility that some kind of demonic forces
thriving on this and,
and,
and being nourished by it.
And that's one of the things that we need to do as human beings is to separate
ourselves from that and say,
no,
we will not do that.
We will not feed that energy.
We will not offer lives each of the beyond.
I don't go with you on that,
but I do in a way.
I don't believe in demons,
but I do.
I think it's undeniable that there have been massive groups of people that have
participated in horrific things.
So what is that if not demonic?
I believe it's,
I believe it's demonic.
I can't prove it.
I can't prove that that's the case.
I just think we should stay open to that possibility that the nature of reality
is so complex and so multilayered that there may be much more going on than we
think and that if we just,
if we just confine our explanations of things to purely economic and material
terms,
we may be missing part of the picture and that when the ancients spoke of angels
and demons to use words,
I'm not saying that I believe in angels or demons as such,
but when they spoke of Lot and light and dark forces,
negative and positive forces playing on the,
on the human race,
maybe they had something going.
Maybe there was something to that.
I always consider the fact that human beings have this incredibly broad spectrum
of possibility,
incredibly bar,
broad spectrum of behavior,
personality of circumstance,
of genetics,
and that there's this Yin and Yang of life.
There's this pull and push of life and that the extreme ends of it are good and
evil.
Good and evil.
Yeah.
And it may,
it may not be a demon,
but it might as well be a demon if you're marching 80,000 people off the side of
a pyramid and cutting their heart out with a fucking stone tool.
Yeah.
That's demonic.
It might as well be,
might as well be a demon.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and that is a,
that is worth considering.
And the,
and the question is what is,
you know,
what is going on here?
I have a very dear friend called James Tiburon who refers to this world that we
live in as a university of [inaudible] that we have,
that we have lessons to learn from oddity,
maybe dualities,
not the whole thing.
Maybe there is an overarching unity and oneness in,
in all things.
But right now here in this incarnation on planet earth,
we have to learn from duality.
And the thing about duality is human beings can choose.
We can always choose,
even in the most straightened and difficult circumstances,
we can always choose for the light rather than the darkness.
We can always choose for good rather than evil.
We don't have to take that act that causes pain and suffering to another human
being.
We never have to do that.
We can always choose not to.
The alarming thing is that people often will choose the act that causes pain and
suffering to others,
and we are defined by our choices.
And this is where we need to grow up as a species and start to choose,
start to choose the light.
Okay.